it's our colorful hour and right now we
are turning to food and helping us eat
our way through the rainbow is chef
author and all-around health guru also
our dear friend of the show it's dan
churchill hey guys great
dianne is it okay if i show a picture of
you
from your instagram yeah i mean uh sure
go ahead okay i'm just saying if you
want to look like dan you want to like
yeah
that i feel like is is that what they
call a thirst trap oh jeez
uh hi mom
okay so when i see that i'm like
i want to do as like how are you so
healthy is that working out and eating
is it like how do you maintain dan uh
and how can we learn from you so
i think the biggest thing i always talk
about this kind of thing is you've got
to enjoy the taste eating colorful food
is just part of what i do right it's
good for you it's tasty i love the
freshness uh look at this table for
example it's right beautiful amazing and
for me
i don't do anything i don't love and it
just so happens that part of my love of
cooking is eating healthier foods and
being active and you look at this and
this is a beautiful colorful dish and i
look at that and i go that is not a
picture of just health that to me just
flavor and taste i have a question is
the sweet potato genuinely better for
you i would suggest yes on a regular
basis okay but a potato in itself if you
actually particularly roast it and allow
it to actually kind of chill and uh it
will actually provide really good starch
that you require but sweet potatoes
particularly ones you see here which
have this beautiful orange this purple
which we'll discuss in a second have
just provided so much more widespread
benefit for your overall body and health
also i love sheep pan baking it's so
easy and unintimidating
[Music]